d'abord la peine qui est proposée
extrêmement lourde trois ans dont un an
ferme avec Brasset électronique donc il
n'ira pas en prison ainsi la peine est
confirmée par la courte cassation qui
est la plus haute instance juridique en
France il aura un bracelet électronique
et donc sur un périmètre qui salt le
sien autour de son domicile il devrait
pas bouger bon mais là on attend
maintenant que la cassation se se
prononce il y a deux choses qui sont
assez troublantes Cyril me semble-t-il
dans ce dossier bon le nom de Nicolas
Sarkozy il est cité dans beaucoup de
dossiers des placements de ces comptes
de campagne l'affaire libyenne Karachi
bon il y a beaucoup de dossiers mais
dans celui-ci ce qui est très
particulier qui devrait nous intéresser
tous parce que finalement un président
de la République un ex-président de la
République c'est un justiciable comme un
autre c'est un justiciable comme un os
qui devrait nous interroger c'est que la
justice a espionné en fait à mission
écoute un client et son avocat un client
et son avocat ce qui peut paraître
complètement illégal parce que en
réalité un avocat ne peut pas dire ce
qu'il a envie de dire par téléphone ou
de visu à son grillon alors il y a plus
de défense possible donc la courte
cassation ce qui est important c'est
qu'elle juge pas sur le dossier et juge
pas sur le dossier et juge en droit
c'est à dire qu'elle va vérifier la
légalité notamment de ce qui a été mis
en place pour elle peut retoquer la
décision mais je regardais Cyril en
arrivant c'est 25 % en moyenne des des
sur 4
il y a ce problème d'écoute quand même
qu'il faut essayer de d'expliciter
pourquoi est-ce que la justice a décidé
sur quelle règle sur quel
fondement d'espionner Nicolas Sarkozy et
son avocate Thierry Herzog c'est un
point un point qui nous intéresse tous
parce que si un jour on a affaire à la
justice on a des choses à dire à son
avocat et on espère pas être écho
écouter par par les Juifs enfin c'est
c'est un vrai sujet et puis la deuxième
chose quand même et là c'est un peu le
dossier politique des choses vous
souvenez que quand Nicolas Sarkozy était
président de la République le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il faisait
pas de cadeau ou magistrats il
[Musique]
voilà vous avez l'histoire et bah
l'histoire est très simple l'histoire
vous avez Nicolas Sarkozy et son avocat
Thierry Herzog qui discute comme un
avocat le fait que son client et la
justice soupçonne que Nicolas Sarkozy
aurait demandé des informations à un
magistrat qui s'occupait d'un autre
dossier un autre dossier qui est
l'affaire est en cours
en contrepartie de l'aide que Nicolas
Sarkozy aurait donné pour que ce
magistrat soit nommé à Monaco c'est un
soupçon c'est ça le fond du dossier et
donc
ils les ont mis sur écoute exactement
mais c'est pour vous ça c'est alors il y
a des cas de figure où vous pouvez être
mis sur écoute si la justice a cherche
une preuve flagrante mais il faut en
référer à des instances d'autorité de la
justice pour des cas de terrorisme en
général bien sûr là ce qui est très
particulier quand même on peut se poser
la question encore une fois Nicolas
Sarkozy c'est un justiciable comme un
autre il est ex-président de la
République mais avons le droit et dans
quelles conditions de mettre sur écoute
un avocat et son client est-ce que c'est
la porte ouverte absolument 3 ans de
prison dont un enferme pour les
téléspectateurs et pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent à 20h34 vous nous dites
Nicolas Sarkozy n'ira pas en prison non
parce que quand les peines sont faibles
en fait vous faites vous purger votre
peine moins de 2 ans vous purger votre
peine avec le fameux bracelet bracelet
électronique c'est-à-dire un objet qui
est sur vous et qui vous et qui contrôle
le périmètre dans lequel vous êtes et ce
périmètre est restreint donc
ça peut être quoi c'est ça peut être son
ça peut être l'endroit où oui où il
habite l'endroit toute la France pas du
tout c'est extrêmement c'est très très
rapproché dans une autre affaire
l'affaire Balkany le périmètre était
extrêmement circonstancié donc le chef
de l'ex-chef de l'État si cette décision
est maintenue par la Cour de cassation
il portera pendant un an et il purgera
ainsi sa peine d'un enferme non pas en
prison mais avec ce
le cas où des gens ont 150 inscriptions
alors dossier ils vont toujours pas en
prison donc mais juste deux ans de
prison avec sursis aussi il y a d'autres
il va être jugés pour d'autres affaires
donc ça c'est ça qui c'est ça qui est
aussi inquiétant parce que ça cumule ou
pas exactement oui c'est un vrai sujet
je rappelle les dossiers il y en a il y
en a il y en a plusieurs il y a le
dossier du financement présumé
évidemment libyens il y a le dépassement
du plafond vous savez vous avez un
plafond à dépenser lorsque vous êtes en
campagne de 15 millions d'euros je crois
que c'est 20 c'est sympa il y a il y a
l'affaire Karachi lorsqu'il était
ministre de du budget il y a il y a
quand même pas mal d'affaires mais
encore une fois les juges doivent juger
dossiers après dossier il y a celui-là
il est ils ont ils ont eu la main lourd
bien sûr Nicolas j'avais juste une
question par rapport à la prison c'est
quand même des choses d'important vous
avez quand même un enferme qui a été
requis pour la faire big Magnan vous
avez jeudi dernier le parquet qui a
envoyé en correctionnel pour le
financement libyen s'il a deux ou trois
condamnations à la prison ferme il y a
un moment donné où il passera par la
case prison je vois pas comment il
pourrait la contourner c'est une bonne
question alors ce sera attention il y a
des appels en ce moment il y a des
procès qui sont en instruction donc
peuvent se confondre donc bien sûr donc
ça il faut enfin il faut voir un
spécialiste mais là on parlait du
dossier de ce dossier là là c'est un
enfer avec un bracelet électronique et
je rappelle qu'il est que son avocat a
formé ce qu'on appelle un pouvoir en
cassation c'est-à-dire que encore une
fois la haute juridiction ne va pas
juger sur le dossier lui-même la courte
cassation jugeant droit c'est-à-dire
qu'elle va vérifier la légalité
notamment des procédures qui ont été
mises en place pour avoir ce soupçon et
là et là et là on verra mais est-ce
qu'il est légal que un un avocat et son
client soit espionné soit mis sur écoute
s'il y a pas pour une autre affaire oui
bien sûr mais ils allaient à la pêche en
fait
de Nicolas Sarkozy dit qu'ils ont été
condamnés sans aucune preuve oui
c'est que des doutes c'est doute mais ce
qui est incroyable aussi pour ajouter un
peu à la réflexion des uns des autres
c'est que dans le droit français et
communément admis le doute il bénéficie
toujours à l'accusé si la Cour a un
doute sur la culpabilité alors en fait
l'accusé s'en sort et là il y a un doute
maîtresse flagrant il y a des soupçons
et il est quand même condamné de la
prison ferme voilà après chacun se fera
évidemment son jugement et son opinion
en fonction peut-être aussi de de de ces
préférences politiques mais c'est vrai
et puis condamné même si c'est un
justiciable comme un autre un
ex-président de la République
d'atteinte c'est la première fois
absolument Jacques Chirac avait été
condamné à deux ans
mais ça atteint aussi pardonnez-moi je
vais peut-être vous paraître un peu
vieillot mais satin aussi l'image de la
France parce que un ex chef de l'État
condamné à un an de prison c'est pas
rien c'est pas rien
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui énormément de
réactions là dessus est-ce qu'il y en a
qui disent que dans la peine est
trop clémente pas du tout non même ses
adversaires politiques que j'entendais
réagir ce matin Cyril mettez en avant le
billet de l'écoute téléphonique c'est ça
mais oui parce que ça concerne tout le
monde en réalité ça peut concerner tout
le monde et voilà alors peut-être que
c'est fondé en droit peut-être que les
juges qui l'ont mis sur écoute avaient
des des preuves et on agit en prévenance
ce qu'on appelle le bâtonnier le leur
chef mais si c'est pas le cas alors il y
a des chances où il y a des risques que
cette décision de justice soit cassées
par la Cour de cassation et ces
opposants disent qu'en fait il y a pas
eu de passage à l'acte il y a pas eu de
nomination en l'occurrence à Monaco
on l'écoutait c'est là-dessus alors que
se joue aussi voilà donc là vous savez
c'est la fameuse affaire Paul bismuth
c'est-à-dire que le président
l'ex-président avait deux lignes et
qu'il a une troisième ligne sous le
pseudo de Paul Bismut qui était en fait
un abonnement prépayé c'est trop blanc
ça quand même oui alors c'est troublant
mais en même temps si vous savez que
vous êtes espionné par la justice et que
vous avez des choses à dire à votre
avocat alors vous pouvez lui dire en
visu mais vous avez pas envie d'être
entendu non plus juste les les écoutes
elles avaient pas lieu d'être puisque il
avait déjà été il y a eu un non-lieu
dans l'affaire bétoncourt oui non-lieu
donc oui bien sûr mais bien sûr bien sûr
c'était pas bien sûr alors c'est c'est
dans cette affaire bête en cours que
Nicolas Sarkozy aurait voulu soustraire
des informations auprès de Monsieur
Gilbert
qui était avocat général à la Cour de
cassation
et qu'il aurait ou qu'on lui aurait fait
prêter l'idée qu'il pourrait l'appuyer
pour cette nomination mais voyez on est
on est sur des hypothèses du
conditionnel de la prudence et là la
sanction tombe trois ans de prison dont
un enferme bon voilà c'est quand même
quoi vous avez comment quand vous avez
appris la sanction ce matin
je vous dis avant le jugement vous
disiez quoi vous disiez ça va passer il
y aura rien bah je me disais est-ce que
certains magistrats vont pas régler
leurs comptes politiquement
bon est-ce que tout ça va être
extrêmement bien fondé mais alors
personne ne s'attendait je pense à trois
ans dont un nom de prison ferme
justement pour qu'on comprenne bien on
va attendre là il va aller dans la cour
de cassation vous avez dit un cas sur
quatre donc qui est 25% en moyenne 100%
oui des juges jugement qualité établi
est-ce que c'est suspensif est-ce que
est-ce qu'il va avoir
que là pour l'instant évidemment
l'ancien président de la République n'a
pas de de bracelet combien de temps ça
peut prendre plusieurs domaine ça peut
prendre plusieurs semaines
alors peut-être plusieurs mois mais ça
va prendre oui ça va prendre un certain
temps mais et c'est là où les choses
risquent aussi de se compliquer vous
lisez tout à l'heure c'est que il y a
d'autres dossiers pendant il y a
d'autres dossiers qui sont en appel mais
ce qu'il faudrait évidemment pas c'est
que la justice sur d'autres dossiers se
laissent influencer par des dossiers
parce que sinon évidemment vous pouvez
avoir des choses absolument en tout cas
c'est vrai tous les gens qui ont qui a
vu et c'est rythme ces opposants
disaient que c'était vraiment une
appropriée et peut-être
très très sévère comme sanction sur ce
dossier là c'est ce que j'ai entendu
même de ces opposants et la Cour de
cassation c'est le dernier recours bien
sûr ma dernière recours donc et mettre
exemple
lui il a interdit d’exercer pendant 3
ans oui et le président de la président
de la République si la si la décision
est confirmée par la Cour de cassation
soit sera privé aussi de ses droits
civiques pendant trois ans c'est-à-dire
inéligible et ne pourra plus voter donc
c'est très humiliant en fait comme
énormément de tweets également bien sûr
pas notamment d'Olivier Marleix c'est
normal le président du groupe LR de
l'Assemblée nationale qui dit des
écoutes illégales une enquête hors norme
au final le simple soupçon d'une
tentative de délit oui à l'évidence
Nicolas Sarkozy victime d'un acharnement
chevelu en témoigner mon estime et mon
affection
il y a eu un acharnement ou pas
si on part du principe c'est un
justiciable comme les autres et que la
peine pour un certain nombre d'experts
Cyril enfin c'est pas moi qui le dit et
quand même très lourde eu égard ou
preuve avancées et une gare à la gravité
des faits parce que trafic d'influence
et corruption il faut voilà c'est un
titre juridique mais en réalité ce qu'on
lui reproche ce qu'on soupçonne c'est
qu'il aurait appuyé un magistrac auquel
il aurait soustrait des informations sur
un dossier pour qu'il soit nommé à
Monaco ce qu'il n'a jamais été donc si
vous voulez ça paraît quand même un peu
léger ça paraît un peu léger ça paraît
un peu
scabreux même pour pour une peine aussi
lourde ça c'est c'est mon point de vue
mais je ne suis pas juriste mais encore
une fois quand j'ai entendu ça ce matin
voilà j'en ai même discuté avec certains
de ces opposants politiques qui étaient
extrêmement surpris de la lourdeur de la
peine et qui tous les écoutes illégales
c'est sur ça que va installer la Cour de
cassation puisque en fait la justice
n'avait pas le droit de le mettre
normalement
normalement la justice dans des cas très
ciblés peut mettre sur écoute des gens
mais ce qui est et je rajoute une chose
Eric Dupond-Moretti qui à l'époque
n'était pas ministre de de la justice à
l'époque où la justice cherchait à
savoir qui aurait pu par par la bande
renseignée
erzog ou Sarkozy a été lui-même on a on
a lui-même regardé ses fadettes c'est à
dire c'est relever de de de téléphone et
Eric Dupond-Moretti évidemment avait
porté plainte en disant mais comment
peut-on écouter un avocat comment
peut-on éplucher les relevés
téléphoniques d'un avocat donc c'est
tout ça qui pèse sur le procès de
Nicolas Sarkozy et c'est vrai et c'est
vrai que je vous dis Cyril moi j'ai
discutais avec des membres du PS ce
matin qui mettait tous en avant le
caractère sans doute totalement illégal
surprenant des écouter téléphoniques
alors pas des écoutes téléphoniques
entre potes Si vous des trafiquants si
vous êtes des terroristes mais entre un
avocat et son client l'avocat il est
tenu au secret professionnel si vous
écoutez sa conversation il y a plus de
secret professionnel il y a plus de
professions d'avocats il y a plus de
défense possible d'accord et l'avocat
peut pas attaquer pour vous non Thierry
il est condamné à la même peine ainsi
que le magistrat l'ancien au cas général
de la Cour de cassation les trois sont
condamnés
je n'ai vu que le pourvoi en cassation
de l'ex-président de la République les
autres je ne sais pas ce qu'ils font
mais regardez même pour Thierry herza
qui est un grand avocat qui est un grand
avocat le fait de l'empêcher de plaider
maintenant parce qu'il est condamné
c'est c'est c'est une demie petite mort
professionnel c'est terrible non le plus
gros scandale vraiment ce sont les
écouter Phoenix alors effectivement un
avocat peut être écouté s'il est mêlé à
l'enquête sauf que l'enquête de départ
les écoutes téléphoniques elles sont
pour les financements libyens donc si on
vous écoute pendant 6 mois forcément on
va trouver non mais on va avoir un
risque de diffamation on va les trouver
des trucs mais là en fait c'est le fait
du hasard ils sont arrivés à où ils ont
été à la pêche ils ont été à la
exactement et un avocat un client si
demain un avocat un client peut être
écouté c'est la mort pour tout le monde
pour tous les justiciables donc c'est un
véritable scandale et ce qui est dingue
effectivement c'est qu'ils sont allés à
la pêche et que dans la logique des
choses il n'aurait pas eu le droit
d'écouter l'avocat puisque l'avocat
n'était pas mêlé à l'enquête originale
si c'était Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est en
train de dire que la peine est trop
légère donc oui
alors l'un des soupçons effectivement
c'est que comme il prend ensuite un un
abonnement prépayé avec ce fameux nom de
Paul bismuth les gens peuvent imaginer
que s'il n'avait rien à cacher il aurait
continué à parler normalement sauf que
ce sachant écouté visiblement ensuite
d'après ce que j'ai compris s'amuser un
peu avec Thierry Herzog à dire d'un peu
des des banalités mais vous avez tout à
fait raison quand la justice va à la
pêche